okay so Donald Trump has a Trump
affiliated hotel in the country of
Panama we've now learned that Trump and
his family profited to the tune of
millions of dollars by letting Colombian
drug cartels among other groups used the
resort to launder money and of course
like with everything Trump related there
are connections to Russia it's never
Equatorial Guinea it's never Chile it
always is Russia Global Witness did an
investigation Newsweek has been reported
out reporting on it pretty extensively
you know how sometimes Trump develops a
resort or hotel but other times someone
else develops it and Trump licenses the
Trump name to the hotel he was having
some tough Financial Times in the early
2000s and that's what he did for a
panamanian a hotel called the Trump
Ocean Club International Hotel and Tower
drug cartels can't write this stuff and
members of the Russian mafia of course
right because there's always a Russia
connection bought units at the hotel in
order to hide the origins of money that
they earned trafficking drugs and
committing other crimes and the Global
Witness investigation says that Trump
realistically earn tens of millions of
dollars with these deals and
specifically they were involved with a
guy named Alexander Ventura Nogueira and
he was involved personally in roughly a
third to half of the sales of the
building's units he was involved with a
bunch of sketchy Russians one guy who
was ultimately jailed in Israel in the
90s for kidnapping another Ukrainian
investor who was arrested for smuggling
people and this is the best part I just
love this the White House was asked for
comment they said no comment no surprise
right no comment so far Ivanka Trump was
asked for comment because she's
allegedly involved in this also no
comment everybody says check with the
Trump Organization so they did and the
chief lawyer for the Trump Organization
is a guy named Allan Garten who said no
one at the Trump organization including
the Trump family has any recollection of
ever meeting or speaking with this
individual by this individual referring
to mr. Nogueira however here's a picture
of Ivanka Trump with mr. Nogueira and
then here is a picture of Donald Trump
with mr. Nagaya and I know they have
pictures with millions of people Sarah
Huckabee sander de seda there's
thousands of pictures with millions of
people doesn't mean they know anybody
but it adds to the interest and this is
interesting for a number of reasons
number one this adds to the list of
Donald Trump's financial conflicts of
interest which are now over 600 for him
and over 1,100 for his family number two
again always a Russia connection why is
it never Madagascar why is it never
whatever country right it's always
Russia and number three this is not a
particularly novel or creative way of
laundering money investing in expensive
real estate is a classic and known way
for criminals to clean money that was
gained illicit Lee and remember Trump
said previously oh I may have sold some
condos to some Russians I'm not really
sure whatever he likes to say that
wreaked of money laundering then and
especially in the wake of these
revelations it reeks even more of money
laundering and this is actually part of
a bigger concern around the finances of
Donald Trump it's widely reported that
there was this period in the early 2000s
where things were not going that well
for Donald Trump financially corporate
bankruptcies Trump writes those off as
him just being really smart and knowing
how to use corporate bankruptcy to his
advantage financial troubles that led to
him starting to license his name all
over the world and then before you know
it Trump is out of financial trouble and
there has never been a really clear
explanation as to just how Donald Trump
got out of trouble so quickly and my
hope is that Robert Moeller's
investigation will explain that and
uncover the answer because the timing of
it is all really pointing to Trump
getting out of financial trouble through
a combination of money laundering to all
sorts of bad actors including Russian
Russian criminals and taking money from
all sorts of people including Russian
oligarchs and and there's one
possibility here which is he got out of
financial trouble because he's really
good at making deals but then why did he
sink into such financial distress in the
first place and the other possibility
which to me is the simplest one is that
Trump did some really sketchy things to
get out of financial trouble and the
trouble and that those things are the
likely
actions that allowed him to become
compromised by foreign nations including
the nation that robert muller is
investigating russia and i really hope
that some day we'll get the full story i
don't know if we ever will the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as one
dollar per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad